all right what you see here is a script
that is actually doing two things for us
one is it's helping us to actually test
this model but also I use it to create
new data so what I pass here into action
is what I'm going to be thinking the
entire time the environment is running
and then all we're using action for is
down here where we figure out did we get
it right or wrong as well as when we go
to actually save the the data the FFT
data that was used to make that
prediction so we can continue training
models so we're just always building the
data set bigger and bigger so with that
let's go ahead and try thinking left and
let's see how we do beat
okay decent basically what I get here is
this is how much data I have just so I
kind of know where I'm at
obviously the that box is what's what's
able to move so I'm thinking left the
hope is that that box continues to move
left there's three action choices left
right or none we can see here that
basically the left was the predicted
action 52% of the time I do actually
collect more more information I'm just
having I started printing it out yet but
prop what happened there was probably
mostly like nun gets predicted a lot so
obviously predicting nun is much better
than predicting right at least and as
you can see we did move beyond that
middle thing so that was okay let's go
ahead and try right
that worked pretty well as well cool
welcome everybody to the second BCI
video the first video the engagement
excitement the passion was off the
charts I even have people poring over
into email just to tell me how excited
they were for of the series which is
really cool to see I'm glad you guys are
interested in either learning about this
or just seeing me fumble about here all
right on to fixes and findings from the
recording of video one tool now the
first major issue was the bursting that
I was experiencing and possibly bursting
was still the wrong word but nobody
corrected me on that so I think you
calling it bursting my solution was
first I tested on my macbook with the
Python or Pi open BCI and I didn't have
that issue and then I tested on Ubuntu
on my main machine because I dual boot
Linux and I didn't have the problem so
my solution was actually just a change
operating system now that might be a
little unruly for everybody so William
Croft linked to this document here which
apparently is under deprecated documents
but I'm assured it still works I haven't
tested it but they say it works so if
you're on Windows and you need to fix
that issue check that out next just to
solidify the actual sampling rate to the
site on board alone which is eight
channels will give us 250 Hertz sampling
rate and then the site on plus the Daisy
board so the board just sits like on top
gets us to sixteen channels which is
what I'm using that is 125 Hertz and
this is a limitation of the Bluetooth
this could be fixed with the Wi-Fi board
which I actually do have I'm just not
going to use it yet I'm told for the IC
the best word is experimental so so it
can be kind of a finicky board to use so
I'm gonna hold off on that until I've
done some other R&D but yeah it
definitely exists and finally the
Nyquist theorem a solo is actually
having a disagreement with Daniel who I
work with about how many samples would
you need raw to reliably sample to some
lesser you
value do you need two times do you need
four times what would you actually need
and we're going back and forth arguing
you know philosophically on the matter
and then I just decided to google it and
sure enough I found like a core opposed
which then linked to this which it you
know providing all the proof and stuff
that I can't validate but I'll assume
it's correct basically the crux is
greater than two so if you want sixty
Hertz you need a raw sample sampling
that is more than 120 Hertz so that
makes sense because also on the open BCI
GUI if you're you know like I'm I'm
using 125 Hertz it goes to 60 okay so
I'll take that as expert validation so
so moving on now that we know those
things what do we what is our objective
right our objective is at least to start
I want to move something on the screen
and as you've already seen I'm starting
to get there but how do we do it so we
need something and I want to use deep
learning so we need something that pass
through this neural network model that
is like useful information so I did
start with PI open BCI and I was doing
my own signal processing with SCI PI
this is fairly complex it's not that
hard but you still you need to account
for any fluctuations in the actual
sampling rate like ideally it's 125 but
sometimes that's coming faster or slower
so so it's hard to account for that and
I just don't know like do I need to
account for that or is that fluctuation
so minimal that it just doesn't matter
so I don't know I don't have the answer
to that so instead what I wanted was
actually something made by someone who's
an expert on the on the matter right and
my assumption is that this right here
this fft plot would contain useful
information for the machine to determine
left right or plausibly none initially I
was thinking just left right but then
the question was we're probably getting
a lot of noise here so maybe introducing
a third action nun would help the neural
network to determine what's truly left
what's truly right and so on so anyway
regardless mostly it's just moved left
right is that information
present inside of here I would I hope so
right that's that is my premise so I
need this like I need this right here
and I I could do it and and like there's
lots of sample code online to do it
there's two major issues one is just
like speed you need to be doing it at a
pretty high rate so that's one thing and
two the same thing as before I can't
really validate code that I don't like I
don't know how to validate it right so
that's that's a problem moving forward
so so really what I want is this I just
want this graph right so anyway I was
discussing with the people at open BCI
over email and they've been super
helpful one of the things that they
linked me to is this Jupiter notebook
that uses the PI open BCI and then also
combines pie cutie graph and I've
actually never personally used pie cutie
craft but it's really cool so it's
actually a really cool example of pie
cutie graph if nothing else and this is
what it should look like so it's almost
like a replacement of the open BCI GUI
especially if we did band power down
here right so in theory it's just kind
of open BCI GUI in Python which was just
cool it was just cool to check it out
but also I was like oh this will have
the FFT code and I can just use that
right so I was like okay great so so I
did try it and actually let me keep this
up one of the issues I faced was when I
ran that this is what I got and
obviously there's a couple of major
issues here so first of all with EEG
data you you want to do two things you
want to filter out things that are
outside of the ranges that you're
expecting to actually receive so you use
like a bandpass filter sorry if I
butchered that there's probably people
cringing right now and then also you
want a notch filter and the knotch
filter is to filter out the 60 Hertz
noise so all the electrical equipment is
just screaming out 60 Hertz noise so you
just get rid of it because it's useless
so yes you can
here they've you know notched that away
but it never reason this was mine and it
looks like I don't have like the sixty
Hertz noise got got filtered out but it
looks like I've got I don't know 63
Hertz like a huge 63 Hertz noise and
that was always there it's not like that
was like a one-time fluke also the
channel data just looks wrong so I don't
know what to think about that but yet
again the recurring theme is I don't
know how to fix it right because I'm not
I don't know what I'm looking at when
I'm looking at this code and it's going
to probably take me months to like learn
all the things I need to learn
maybe not months weeks but a while to
figure out okay here's where something's
going wrong and hopefully I'm assuming
it's nothing wrong with the headset so
so so there was that
but then I was linked to the actual GUI
which has a section which was up
initially called networking which allows
you to take anything you want from here
and pass it to Python over something
called LS l which I had never heard of I
think lab streaming layer basically if
you use this you can just set a constant
stream over Python which I'll show in a
little bit and then you just connect to
it right and then you can choose what do
you want to pass over that stream and I
was like yeah fast Fourier transform
let's do it so so that's what I wanted
but uh initially I threw 16 in here and
it just really wasn't clear to me so
like if I if I go over here you know it
just says like FFT can be now transfer
you know sent over LSO which is cool
then it sort of has some information
here about for certain data types you
want to change a number Chan to match
the data type but I wasn't really sure
what that was talking about so I threw
16 in here and I had a really hard time
figuring out what was going wrong but
basically I was getting data that they
look like this which doesn't look like
this at all but it's very clear there's
like either wrapping going on here or at
multiple data sets but I couldn't figure
out what was going on there but then
eventually over email yet again I was
given this which I
that they I think this should be shared
like on that page personally but
basically it just says you're going to
get 125 floats one for each bin per
channel and as I'm looking it's like
okay so really what I want to throw in
here is 125 for the channels and once I
did that everything worked so to show
you an example of that
[Music]
what was it blue to be Python 3 2 so
I'll just run that one let's see oops
not Python 3 Python 3 7 so this is at
least closer to what what we're
expecting now obviously this is a single
frame I'm probably moving my head so
we're seeing quite the fluctuation there
but anyway yes this is the data I was
after so now finally I've got that
information I can walk away from the
subject that I am very weak I don't know
really anything about beyond I've worked
with Fourier transform data before
though but it was for audio but I can
finally take this and do the DSP or
digital signal processing that I do know
about which is passing that through a
neural network and hopefully classifying
right left or right left none and so on
so then the question is okay what kind
of neural network are we gonna use also
how do we make data and all that stuff
so now what I'm gonna do is go over the
actual code there okay so this was kind
of like the first code that I grabbed to
get the LSL or pius LSL data to get the
fft or fast Fourier transform graph
which basically is this data here so
again you just choose that type you can
name it and type it here and then you
say 125 channels because we're sampling
at 125 Hertz and then you just hit start
here so once you've done that you're
done right you just leave this UI up and
it's it's just streaming that
information which is super useful
because if you've ever had to work with
like Siri
connections to things it's kind of a
pain in the butt and very often you're
just cycling power over and over and
over it's very hard to like iterate on
the code there's usually like clean ways
to exit but often you'll hit an error or
something like that and you just it's
it's pain so this is super cool because
you don't have to deal with that so
right now this is just streaming out
this information and then in the code we
just collect that information so we're
just saying hey give us the stream
that's of type EEG you could either do
it that way or you could grab it
specifically by name which is pretty
cool like I said I've never used Pi LSL
and I'm guessing most of you probably
haven't either so cool and then we can
grab that specific stream it'll be the
only one in this case because we're not
streaming anything else on the other
channels but you could stream the other
things as well so you connect to that
and then again it's gonna come in chunks
of 125 and as we already saw in the docs
it's a hundred and twenty five data
points per channel we have sixteen
channels so we're going to get sixteen
channels of 125 data points and we're
just gonna keep cycling through that so
one thing I could do is rather than say
five we could do this I don't know for I
don't know 500 or 5,000 and then let me
go ahead and open in terminal here and
we'll say Python 3 7 2 stream fps so
this is just the actual frames per
second so we're seeing we're getting
about I don't know 20 to 23 now it's 25
I did notice that it starts off kind of
slow and then eventually will go to
about 25 and then when it's done we'll
actually see the see the graph hopefully
if it's finishes anytime and then here
I'm just plotting the data Qian up to 60
Hertz so we actually have more
information right so what we could say
is let's go back to 5 and just plot the
whole thing we actually have data all
the way to 125 Hertz possibly why
actually not sure why that is angry at
me why are you angry
huh I don't know why I got angry me
there anyway
so as you can see it does actually go
beyond that but again Nyquist theory
anything beyond sixty I suppose is
probably useless like we can't actually
it's not reliable information so we toss
it so anyway the information we actually
want is at this point here so now we can
take this data and we can pass it
through a neural network but we have
many questions what kind of neural
network do we want to use right and I
know most people are gonna think
recurrent neural network but if you've
been watching any of my tutorials
recently on machine learning recurrent
Nets are so 20:18 really confidence bar
also the king of sequential data so so
we're probably at least what I've
started with is a one-dimensional
confident and I'm actually not even
using anything like attention I'm not
passing a sequence of information
I'm literally passing just one this data
right here and that's it and then we're
just constantly making predictions at
about twenty-something ish frames per
second so it just becomes kind of a
combination of all those predictions
give it and that will create what ends
up actually being moved so so the first
time I did it basically it's just a
bunch of code that let's see stream by
blah environment you already saw the
environment so I'm not really going to
show that and then this just kind of
this was the first time because I didn't
have a model to move something around
basically I say hey here's the action
I'm going to think about and then we
actually run the the environment we run
through that environment and then we
save that data to whatever that action
is so now I've got this data directory
and we've got left none and right
actions and it's just full of numpy
arrays of just a bunch of FFTs of the
thought right so I've done that with
left none and right and like I said
right now I'm just passing it through a
1d comment possibly later I'll do
multiple samples per thing that I pass
so it could be a 1d continent it could
probably a 1d continent with like a
tension or something like that but right
now I'm just trying to get a decent
amount of information I'll probably also
try recurrent net I just confidence are
doing better also commnets are way
faster so I can much more quickly
iterate through things test them and run
it live because what I ended up doing
was after I train a model I actually run
this script here which loads that model
and then hey I say I'm going to think
left it's going to use that model to
read that FFT data make its prediction
and hopefully go left and at the end it
saves the data under whoops not there
here it'll save that data as a left
right or whatever so anyway this is the
script that I usually end up running the
most which is just simply constantly
running models and then I'm it's almost
like like two things are happening at
the same time we're creating data and
I'm actually kind of testing the model
at the exact same time so there's that
and then also I'm just collecting a
bunch of data in terms of accuracy so
later I can create confusing confusion
matrixes matrices and all that so that's
where I am right now
I just ran through a ton of things I
totally understand that was a lot of
information at some point I will release
the at least the training data I just
want a little bit more I want to make
sure I'm on the right track I'm still
like totally second-guessing things and
like not really sure if it's working but
the at least so far the left right and
done I am consistently better than
random it's about somewhere between so
there's three options right so that
means random is 33% so if I'm thinking
don't move write more it's about 50%
well on none it's about it's like 60 70
80 % accurate like if I'm not thinking
left or right it's very accurate and
I've guessed that's probably cos
nothing's going on but if I think left
or right that's was very difficult for
the machine to differentiate
and again there's a 33% chance to get
that right and I'm getting about
mid-forties percent accuracy so I know
there's something there but as you could
see in the beginning there's a lot of
like wiggling going on and then there's
plenty of times I'm thinking left as
hard as possible
and that box goes right so definitely
lots of things to work through more data
to create possibly changing up the model
whatever and if I even if I go with the
recurrent net I still have the data that
would be required for that so really
right now I'm just collecting FFT data
on thoughts of actions so from there I
can go many ways unless I end up
deciding FFTs not informative enough
right garbage in garbage out so like I
said though I think it is purely because
I've got an edge clearly already with a
pretty basic one-dimensional confident
like right now the confident is I think
32 by 3 but I've been trying like a ton
of different ones but I can pull that up
as well yeah so right now we're doing a
32 by 3 and that's that's really it and
that seems to be actually working which
is really surprising I didn't think I
was going to be able to get results as
quickly as I did but once I got the the
FFT data I was able to start training
something at least so but that said I
think left and right should be pretty
simple to detect just based on channels
alone so anyway we'll see lots more to
go if you've got questions comments
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
those below also shout out to another
batch of new channel members Eduardo Mon
you know Esteban Benjamin Bianchi Dara
gamma mark Ebisu Wow Pedro Vasconcelos
of tech Sierra and James Seifert thank
you guys very much for your support you
guys are awesome that's it I'll see you
guys in another video